ae
obrigado obrigado e adeus e obrigado
balde
bom dia criar grandes chances mais a
faculdade de ciências e tecnologia para
gestão integrada também a terex a abi e
vim para os contar desta experiência do
tocá rufar
não é fácil estou extremamente nervoso
pois nem a vinha no carro vinha vária
ouvir a rádio e ouviu a orientação do
caetano veloso que eu dizia se meu
coração de criança não perdeu a
esperança de um dia ser tudo que ele ser
tudo o que quer
achei meu coração de criança não perde a
esperança de um dia ser tudo o que
querem
isso porque tanto cara assim é preciso
ter um coração mall é preciso conseguir
fazer o nosso coração muitas vezes duro
tornar o mal educado com essa
sensibilidade com meus dois tocaram
antes de entrar nos disse que queria que
eles ficassem com deus não é fácil
também diz o seguinte é música
gostava da música nem sempre consegue
obter
nem mesmo as orquestras sinfônicas às
vezes conseguem fazer o que eu chamo um
milagre
quero fazer música se conseguir atingir
esse milagre
nós temos que deixar de ser nós próprios
e que o momento deixamos de ser nós
próprios e o conjunto pode ou não
atingirem esse momento milagre neste
momento único que é muito difícil de
explicar
só consegue perceber realmente quem não
está aqui numa foi quem chega esse
estado de espírito é consegue finalmente
entender o que nós partimos press
planeta ea umidade fazer música
vou contar um pouco da história toca à
fala com isso começou
embora muitas das questões sejam apenas
logísticas como fazer um projeto como
sonhar com o projeto como passo a passo
concretizar o muitas pessoas chegam
perto dos pés de informação para fazer
um projeto político e ao longo destes
regional vamos começar a ver certamente
saberão já formaram mais 50 orquestras
de percussão a ciência toca a falha
geralmente as questões começam por andré
que se arranjar os instrumentos
quanto custam alguns recuos de base
podemos expulsar vou trabalhar algumas
partituras algumas idéias e costumes
falas quanto é que isto custa morreu
trabalhamos sobre os custos do projecto
idêntico
acontece que no final depois de duas ou
três horas de reunião a volta dos custos
de logística eu chega participam e deixo
as pessoas querem fazer o projeto
identifica o nosso de finalmente os 15
que não comecem nos estamentos o projeto
não são os instrumentos objeto não são
as falas objeto não são aquilo que se
adquire o projeto é algo antes disso o
projeto é conseguir reunir ao todo 16
pessoas que têm uma grande convicção de
que vão chegar a determinado sítio
musical
nós chamamos a nós
hoje com finas e às vezes confia porque
acho que temos todos um pouco do fias e
essa é parto do seu fiesta falta alguma
forma as vezes até revoltada
este coração duro que nós trabalhamos
para se tornar um processo mall que
neste momento se entrega e às vezes
conseguem esse milagre então objeto com
soul 18 e 40 anos até que aos 40 anos
para assumir a minha vida
quem conhece uma vez que eu tinha
servidas com os gatos e já tem de sair
a última vida com o sócio 40 anos com
este projeto
acho que será um grande músico em
portugal
já em 1983 em primeira discussão
tive uma carreira fenomenal subir muito
e quem doar acima exames quentes foram
basicamente de uma luta contra o toque
os camponeses desistir de ser músico
sting fora em cuidados e depois
finalmente que está em portugal por
causa dos meus pais tinha 36 anos
já um homem de desistir de ser músico
colegas meus convenceram voltar a ser
músico e o cheio meta inicialmente
disseram que era um dos poderes para a
música eu não voltar a tocar um pouco a
pouco com muito medo também já não tinha
instrumentos em vender os instrumentos
reclama
aliás vende tudo dito
osama bin laden que envolveram os
instrumentos envolveram também muito
carinho e muita força e eu comecei a ser
músico voltou a montar o grupo tinha já
há muitos anos e que os meus colegas
montamos um novo espetáculo
levamos um novo disco estávamos em 1996
o espetáculo de percussão
se o percussionista
nesse espetáculo vamos ver visita de
duas pessoas do joão brites dá conselhos
e até 6 anos tiveram peso nos bastidores
falaram de que há dois anos vai
acontecer esta mundial - boys por 98 e
nós estamos a falar com alguns músicos e
convidá-los para elaborar um espetáculo
à volta do instrumento que o grão 13
o prédio foi convidar professores um
espetáculo à volta e ver que outros
outros e me convidaram para fazer o
espetáculo a volta do bumbum que quer
utilizar sub 16 mil eu estive lá na van
que a apple está na zona dos bons e eu
era meu pai com 45 anos ouvia eram
dezenas e dezenas de homens
a marshall de jesus nas posições já
tinha essa recordação
alguns autores joão brites apresentar os
bônus não é conjuntos o 45 é combater
iam talvez como eu tenho na memória - os
60 180 sem então
trabalhei na idéia é convidar alguns
colegas músicos e trabalhar a idéia do
meio
eu tenho eu disse isso vamos fazer uma
orquestra com 100 ou mais pois meu pai
trabalhou muitos anos na publicidade que
o grêmio tem que exigir a desfazer o mal
que esta com 300 educadores maior festa
do mundo começam os sonhos então andamos
maus a obra esta estava nos apoios já um
cachê com dois anos de existência em
cache depois de fazer o projeto é
implementar o projeto geram 10 por cento
daquilo que iríamos precisar para
trabalhar durante dois anos para montar
a ok é velada que sabem que ficamos com
bom porte optantes lá conseguimos
orçamento no final 10 por mês com o
santos então colegas meus na altura a
minha companheira pois sabe que manuel
alceu
poucos meses depois os donos início
juntamente com três colegas músicos
também porque os tenistas também teremos
quatro gatos pingados de tudo homens
fizemos um plano o plano consistia em
começamos a dar aulas nas escolas com os
nossos fãs do pato instrumentos e pôs a
aliciar jovens para dois anos depois
temos uma orquestra apresenta mesmo
marcar vamos exibir nesta lá vamos
trabalhando fizemos apresentamos a
proposta é quase 50 câmeras não se teve
nos proporcionarem e finalmente 3
adicionamos outros boa e do chão
mesmo assim estávamos pai com 30% do
orçamento
trabalhamos bastante e sei que avançamos
bastante mas sem instrumentos tudo com
palmas
nós fizemos nosso primeiro grande
encontro cv que juntamos a todos onde
nessa altura eram 800 e de 30
trabalhadores antes falou que tal espa e
então estávamos no pacto cicv todos com
palminhas outros 30 garrafas com
pedrinhas e no final eu vou explicar
esta criança consegue falar nisso que
não são não era lançar os instrumentos e
2 têm não comecem os investimentos
comecem por do trabalho
nós ficávamos palmas cargos de chefias
com pedrinhas pouco mais um outro 13
anos revela que os turistas e tal ponto
que não estávamos a conseguir fazer era
alinhar no pátio do cicv já que está
fazendo um som mais todos a linha de
esquerda temos uma estrutura pelo menos
uma orquestra
cada um sabe a sua posição é de 70 lá
longe que as palminhas e fez cinco e
sete anos nas escolas a e machado
machadão amargos como uma orquestra e
depois dar a volta e aprender estudo que
na altura não seria bem vindo aprender e
lembrar que querem fazer isso tudo aí os
militares
você ver filmes paradas militares e
total prevê que se mantém todos esse
compasso mesmo sentimental e mais nós
fazemos o espaço ao minhas amigas
palminhas já estávamos um pouco
inspirados nesse encontro enquanto e 31
de agosto de 1997 em março
já estávamos adaptados new times fala
dos grandes instrumentos já tínhamos um
grande grupo de trabalho já ficado
aconteceram vários milagres um desses
milagres foi o dia 31 de agosto
elimar uma tela que fosse dado dois dias
antes
o encontro realizou os treinamentos já
estávamos um pouco dos prazos e eu falei
pai cantava a multidão e diz sua atenção
nós vamos aesp nós vamos ter uma
orquestra nós vamos atuar com 300 com ou
sem instrumentos
não é porém tenham calma quando eu
estava lá a direção do inatel que chamou
estava lá o visual que influencia e
chamaram meses calculou a diesel o
vice-presidente qual é o problema do
tipo chamaram então qual é o problema
então eles falta nos 300 instrumentos
que esse custo x 150 o inatel vai se
posicionar
foi o primeiro grande milagre então
propuseram de fazer um uma semana da
entrega
passado pouco tempo de entrega foi tal
maneira emotiva que o dia observam os
restantes 150 bom e passa a passo a
passo a passo com primos expô fomos ao
palco pontos educadores todos com esta
farda esta não residentes que até deus e
como fizemos o nosso jeito
durante muitos anos fomos e sinimbu
outras pessoas a fazer o projeto
a nossa segurança e de terem surgido
dezenas e dezenas de outros projetos e
hoje em dia em 1983 eu era talvez o
único serviço em portugal aliás dizia
perguntar o que fazer diz o
percussionista porque o percussionista
talvez bateia não toca às pressões com
as mãos não eram os bons de 1 de março
de 2011 já temos uma série bastante
composta com auditório e aconteceu
temos o incêndio
provocado por umas obras e que mostrou
tudo em mãos na edição de vídeos e
fotografias livros centenas de
instrumentos e taticamente todo o que
tínhamos juntos até essa data
foi um momento histórico pois o momento
para o vôo é que o que eu digo quando
querem formar um teste tocá rufar voltou
ao seu adm juntos outra vez sem
instrumentos na rua e não estamos
novamente este ano a boa
fomos requena instrumentos fomos reto em
faltas
estamos aqui hoje ao fim destes anos é
prova que o projeto
este projeto não são as paredes não só
os instrumentos não é que o que se vê é
que o que às vezes se sente que é este
milagre das pessoas conseguirem juntar
se e aspirarem a fazer a fazer este
milagre
esta inspiração que são réus que me
inspirou a mim toda vez que tocam eu
sabem quantas vezes chora quando deus
palco quando se atingem que é o ponto
faz me chorar e faz muitas pessoas em
portugal senhora é simplesmente
inexplicável é coisa mais fantástica do
mundo ea essência do projeto e não
experiência quem agradecemos que tenho
ouvido que ali será um teste por ter
estado aqui porque os liberam hoje foi
que eu produzir foi tocar com deuses
obrigado a todos